hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice weekend improving game played
between Michael Tao and Tigran Petrosian
before we check out this very nice game
let's check out one of the photos I have
installed for the photo challenge for
this video it's not gonna be too
difficult specially for those of you who
are constantly improving your vast
knowledge so best of luck to everyone
who is the little boy in this photo as
you can see he's holding a simultaneous
exhibition the photo was taken in 1920
it's a pretty famous photo pretty sure
most of you should know who he is and
you know he will grow up to do amazing
things so best of luck to you all
now regarding this game it's a blitz
game played between michael stalin
Tigran Petrosian it's not very often I
will show a blitz game but when a game
is as exciting as this one and
especially if it's against the frames
defense then I will show it and I don't
have a photo of this game in particular
but I do have one photo of a towel
playing against Petrosyan from 1975 it's
this photo is it's not of the greatest
quality but it will definitely help us
you know get in the mood to check out
this game so there's the photo I do hope
you enjoyed it and now let's check it
out
just a second sorry about that okay so
II for and like we said ecigs we have
the French defense on the board
d4 d5 and now that was four Knights to
d2 not going 4/9 to c3 oh that's pretty
much going into Bishop 2 before the
vinegar variation so basically Knight to
d2 the Taurus variation avoiding the
whenever we have Knight to e7 Knight G
to f3 and Knight to d7 so if you look at
this formation when you see something
like this you are either playing against
you know a total new or against a former
world champion such as Steve and
Petrosyan and you know that some some a
very nice defensive setup is is about to
emerge we have Bishop to d3 c5 and now e
captures on d5 here just if you face the
Frank defense a lot you should never be
afraid of a move such as c4 even if you
castle here and black does push C for
the
it's not really all that good for black
yes he will make her light square bishop
a bit less active but you know it's not
a problem you will challenge his
advancement on c4 would be three if he
pushes to be filed in with a four later
on so if you play against the French you
know never fear the c4 move he captures
on d5 wait all night capture Sun d5 and
tell castles we have seek a person
before and now capturing a d4 with the
night immediately is perfectly fine but
you know always you always have to make
it interesting so nice to be three just
seeing if if maybe this will you know
awaken something creative in Petrosyan
and maybe he will start playing this
game crazy as well nice the c5 so he
would definitely enjoy if thought
captured and c5 and he could develop his
bishop with tempo tapas Bishop to b5
check
we have Bishop to d7 blocking and now
Bishop captures on d7 Queen captures and
now Queen captures on d4 and Petrosyan
goes Queen to a4 now offering a trade of
Queens which is a very nice idea if
thought would captured and Knight
captures you constantly you're
constantly pressuring the b2 pawn rook
is coming to see a this will be very
nice it would be an excellent position
for black and on the other hand after
Queen to a4 if you go Knight captures on
c5 then after Queen captures Knight
captures Bishop captures and Knight
moves Bishop to e7 black definitely
equalized material is equal but black
has two developed pieces this rook will
be developed it very nice-looking both
castle you can double up on the C file
or always well for black here you know
if someone's better than definitely
black is better here so after Queen to
a4 now plays C for not allowing the
Queen exchange and if you see a move
like c4 you're probably thinking wow
that that truly is a madman's move
what happens after Knight captures on b3
your queen is under attack and also if
you capture in the night then Queen
captures rook so what what is Todd's
idea when he played c4 well exactly that
so petrosyan played knife capture some
b3 and top plays a character some b3 now
Petronas Queen is under attack and also
his knight on d5 is under attack
so basically petrol
Tally's forcing Petrosyan to capture his
rook on a 1 so we have Queen captures
and now C captures on d5 and it's a it's
a very difficult position for black here
what do you play here you definitely do
want to castle if this bishop moves with
tempo your queen gets under attack you
can't really develop something like
Bishop here Bishop here then Queen to g7
will be an option and if you try
something like
queenside castle which seems like a move
that completely you know it gets black
out of trouble then Queen to c4 is
deadly you don't really have a good move
here if you go King to b8 then Bishop to
f4
the king is in check you lose the Queen
here and if you don't if you play
something like King here but that's no
better then comes pawn captures pawn
captures and Knight to e5 check King
moves and now comes Bishop to g5 this
also comes with check King these six and
now Queen D for checking moves and now
Queen captures and the 8th and this is
checkmate so there you have it
so after this C captors and d5 petrosyan
tried Queen to a6 and Queen to a6 is an
excellent defensive resource of course
it takes a Petrosyan to find a move like
this and here capturing on e6 is a the
engines recommendation but it's a blitz
game tall doesn't go for the stall goes
for the active rook to e1 simply putting
a rock in front of blacks King Petrosyan
castles Queen side here we have Bishop
to f4 not allowing a black King to
escape reacting to b8 also rook to c1
will be a very dangerous move now we
have rook to d5 capturing and now comes
rook to see one check King to d8 and now
comes the Bishop to g5 check of course
the rook can capture the bishop as the
rook is pinned and King to e8 displayed
here by petrosyan a move like f6 doesn't
really work
then comes Bishop captures pawn captures
Queen captures with check and after King
moves orbital blocks it's all the same
Queen captures on h8 and now white is
actually up in material he's up opponent
in a much better position so after this
Bishop to g5 check
Petrosyan goes king te 8 and now
of course everyone is expecting Rock to
see it the problem would work to see a
this is that petrosyan has a defensive
idea against this king to d7 and after
rook to the 8th check King to c7 and now
after Queen to a4 check Bishop to d6 and
black black managed to escape and he
will defend this position Queen captures
an f7 keeping escapes and it will be a
nice King King walk for black but
Petrosyan is always up for King walk so
this would be very good for black so
after this King to e8 move at all played
well what what could stop play other
than a towel move top plate Knight to e5
and what's the idea of course Petrosyan
can now capture tiles Queen but the idea
behind Knight to e5 is that night now
guards d7 square and of course capturing
immediately loses to rook to CH check
the King has nowhere to go the night and
Bishop create a wall in front of the
king and after up to d8 rook captures
will be a very nice Opera House
checkmate so after this Knight to e5
move Petrosyan so ok there's no way I
can allow rook to see it check he played
b6 but B 6 is actually a terrible
terrible move ahead and style
immediately takes advantage of this and
there is only one move that completely
crushes black here you are tall here
pause the video and defeat Tigran
Petrosian so I will give it a couple of
seconds for you you know if you want to
consider solving this disposition it's
okay for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are a true man
of the Opera because here as this was
played in the game top plate into a 4
check and after Queen to f4 check rosin
simply resigned at the game if he does
anything other than capturing the Queen
then the Petrosyan loses the Queen and
the game and of course if Queen captures
then we get the same idea hello the
Opera House checkmate rook c8 check rook
has to block and then rook captures and
we have this rook bishop combo that is
deadly and whitest check the black is
checkmated and okay after this Queen to
a for the tours and resigned the game
but it's very interesting after this
a weasel move by night if by tyldus 95
move a patrol and actually could have
defended but he didn't find the the
strongest continuation one move
definitely wins the game for black and
it's also you know a very nice idea
Petrosyan was you know under a lot of
pressure it was a bliss game he's
playing against tall tall he's attacking
him so it's not really the same if you
want feel free to pause the video here
and try to refute 2095 idea so as usual
I will give it a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you know you have just
refuted an attack by Michael tile and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy
the show the idea is Bishop to c5 after
the Bishop to c5 it's no longer the same
if white plays rook captures then the
same idea does not apply black doesn't
have to capture the Queen and allow this
very nice checkmate
black can simply play Queen to a1 check
and now the King has nowhere to go you
have to block this ok the rook is
guarded by the bush but simply Queen
captures with check Bishop captures and
now route capture screen and yes white
does have two pieces and like this have
two looks but there is no defense
against rook to d1 white can't defend
both checkmate and the bishop on c1 so
either g3 or King to f1 you have to
block checkmate and then after rook to
d1 check he moves and now you have two
rooks again turn against the knight a
completely winning position
unfortunately for Petrosyan he did not
see Bishop to c5 after this 95 this
sneaky move by tal he played b6 and it's
all over not a queen to a4 and a
beautiful beautiful victory for me a
hotel resembling that of of Paul Morphy
hence the title of the video well there
you have it so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Ahmed Gaudi
Rahman Valley or ramalingam Paul V
tomorrow
Vladislav mr. Luke and Simmons a request
for a contribution to my channel thanks
a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon probably with a couple
of more of
or suggestions and then we'll see we'll
see if I will be covering the entire
Luton tournament if not we will continue
with our magnus carlsen vs Vishwanathan
Anand World Chess Championship match so
thank you all and I will see you soon